تذكيرا بالنكبة. فالجزائر وتونس
والمغرب وان اختلف القادة يبقى
الكبسة السعودية قبل مواجهة
المنتخب السعودي جولة الاخيرة من
ماكون يغرد بالعربية ويشيد بجهود
قطر في انجاح كأس العالم. اعلام
مرحلة المجموعات لكأس العالم.
فهل هناك سر في الكبسة يا ترى?
اردوغان يقول ان علاقات تركيا
وسوريا تتحسن مثلما تحسنت
التركية شنت ضربات على الفرات
وعين الغرب باكثر من اربعمائة
بالمدفعية الثقيلة التركية يطال
مطار مينجل عسكري السوري. وقالت
وكالة هاوار القريبة من حزب
العمال الكردستاني ان القوات
تكنولوجيا الفضاء العسكري وذلك
تهديدا خطيرا على التفوق
وافعالها. الاحداث والتطورات.
المنتخب المكسيكي يطلب تناول
الانتخابات تظهر ان الشعب
التيواني يريد السلام. سوريا
مسمى وخزائن الغرب تنفد ليأتي
اصحاب عيون الضيق ويفتحون
بارزاني ملف الامن وتأمين الحدود
العراقي. لننتقل ونضمد جرحنا
منشأة بينها ستون منزلا في مدينة
سلفيت الفلسطينية في سياسة
السابق بتهمة الخيانة العظمى.
حرب اوكرانيا تمتد الى اجل غير
والمحيط الهادئ فهل يرد اصحاب
العيون الضيقة? واما في تايوان
الكيان الاسرائيلي غاضب من
جماهير تونس في مونديال قطر. حيث
والعراق على خط النار. التعرض
للضربات انتهى وحان وقت الرد
رفع التوانسة اعلام فلسطين
بالدقيقة الثامنة والاربعين
اسرائيلية ممنهجة للتهجير. السجن
مدى الحياة لرئيس جزر القمر
مع السيسي دام لخمس واربعين
دقيقة فيالى نتائج السياسة
حلم الشعوب معلقا بامل فلسطين.
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يهدم مائة
العراقي محمد السوداني في بغداد
مع رئيس اقليم كردستان نجرفان
الاخر ونقصد سوريا وبعد ضربات
جوية ها هو القصف المكثف
علاقتهم بمصر ودول الخليج.
فالسياسة لا تتحمل القطيعة حد
قذيفة هاون وبمشاركة ضربات
الدبابات لكن الرئيس التركي
جعل دول القارة العجوز تطرق باب
الصين دولة ثم اخرى بحسب
وصف فهل حان وقت التفاوض فبعد
قطيعة دامت تسع سنوات ها هو
اردوغان يجتمع بالسيسي وبوساطة
قطرية واعترف اردوغان ان لقاءه
حلفاء امريكا. الايام تمضي وما
هي مسألة وقت حتى يحكم اصحاب
العسكرية الروسية. وهي غواصة
النووية وغواصة وبين هذا وذاك
ناخذ ما يجري هناك بعين الاعتبار
او على محمل الجد. الصين تكسب
نوويتين بمواصفات حديثة وفقا
لمصادر مطلعة في مجال الصناعة
والتدفئة. هذه المراكز من قسوة
الشتاء لتزيد روسيا من مخاوف
احضانهم للدول الاوروبية. فهل
تصل بكين لاهدافها مبكرا بسبب
المخطط الايراني للاجتياح
المحتمل. وقال مستشار الامن
لسيادة البلاد من قبل ايران
وتركيا. بينما بحث رئيس الوزراء
القومي العراقي قاسم الاعرجي ان
القيادة العراقية لا باي انتهاك
الايراني باجتياح بري للعراق
بغداد واربيل تنسقان لاجهاض
تساقط الثلوج على اوكرانيا
ازدادت اوضاع الاوكرانيين سوءا
فربما لن تحتاج الصين للغزوة
فعلى اثر نتائج الانتخابات
هامش قمة العشرين. وخصصت كندا
مليارا وسبعمائة مليون دولار في
المحلية التايوانية الهزيلة
استقالت رئيسة تايوان من منصبها
باطلاق خطة جديدة للمواجهة. جاء
ذلك بعد ايام من لقاء ساخن بين
استراتيجيتها الجديدة لمواجهة
الصين التي وصفتها مزعجة في اسيا
كرئيس الحزب الديموقراطي التقدمي
الحاكم وبكين تقول ان نتائج هذه
الامريكي. لكن كندا تسبح عكس
التيار وتشعل الصراع مع الصين
قوة الفضاء في الجيش الامريكي ان
الصين حققت تقدما مذهلا في تطوير
التقارير الغربية فهل تكون الصين
الخلاص للاوروبيين لتعلنها رئيسة
اوروبا باستيراد الغاز الامريكي
بدلا عن الغاز ولكن ارتفاع السعر
عليها والعراق وسوريا لن تسكتا
بعد اليوم. وبعد تهديد النظام
للسلام ام ان هناك مآرب اخرى خطط
بكين بدأت تؤتي ثمارها حيث بدأت
السلام في العالم لمواجهة ما
سماه بالوضع الجديد فهل هي خطة
الامريكي اربعة اضعاف وازمة
الطاقة وكذلك التضخم في اوروبا
رئيس الوزراء الكندي جوستن ترودو
والرئيس الصيني شي جين بينغ على
بتوجيه ضربات خلف الخطوط ويمكن
تسليم هذه القنابل في وقت مبكر
ورخيصة يتم تثبيتها على صواريخ
متوفرة بكثرة مما يسمح لك يا
التسريبات الى الكرم الحربي حيث
اكدت الدفاع البريطانية ارسال
للارهاب ليس ملزما قانونيا
وبالمقابل لا رغبة لدينا في ان
الى زعيم كوريا الشمالية يعرض
فيها التعاون من اجل تسريع
بينما يدرس البنتاجون تزويد
اوكرانيا بقنابل دقيقة صغيرة
العيون الضيقة العالم ليوجه
الرئيس الصيني شي جين بينغ رسالة
في كل محافظة. وتوفر هذه المراكز
الكهرباء والماء والطعام
قال ان قرار البرلمان الاوروبي
بشأن اعتبار روسيا دولة راعية
الاوكران بتحديث ترسانتها
النووية. حيث ضمت غواصتين
بانقطاع الكهرباء ليامر
الزلانسكي بتشييد مراكز الصمود
فكيف سيرد الروس? ولا زلنا في
معركة الاستخبارات. هنا قال رئيس
فاعل يا بوتين? وبالعودة الى
الحرب الاوكرانية. ومع بداية
قد حذر مرارا من مغبة تسليم
اسلحة كهذه لاوكرانيا. فماذا انت
الايرانية الى روسيا لدعمها في
الهجوم على اوكرانيا وذلك حسب
من ربيع عام الفين وثلاثة وعشرين
وذلك حسب رويترز. لكن بوتين كان
نفى ذلك واكد استمرار قواته على
المحطة النووية. ومن حرب
شحنة من صواريخ الدقيقة الى
اوكرانيا في اطار المساعدات
الروسية تستعد لمغادرة محطة
زبروتش النووية لكن الكريملين
وكالة الطاقة الاوكرانية ان هناك
مؤشرات فعلية على ان القوات
موقع اكسيوس الامريكي. اسرائيل
تتخلى عن روسيا للضغط على ايران
استخباراتية للغرب ودول الناتو
تكشف تفاصيل نقل الاسلحة
مثل تايوان وكوريا الجنوبية حيث
تواصل الصين اختبار قوتها
مستعدون لاستئناف الحوار مع
موسكو بشأن الاستقرار
ان واشنطن غير مستعدة لنقل
الاسلحة رئيسية من مناطق حساسة
الاتحاد الاوروبي. ويمكن ان يؤدي
الى انقسام الوحدة عبر الاطلسي
هدايا الاستخبارات حيث قدم
الكيان الاسرائيلي معلومات
للصواريخ والقذائف فيوم واحد من
القتال في اوكرانيا يوازي شهرا
المستخدمة في حرب اوكرانيا
مذهلة. وكييف بحاجة مستمرة
باستمرار لتجد الولايات المتحدة
نفسها بين مطرقة روسيا وسندان
الصين. فاين المفر? ليعلنها
مسؤولون في الناتو كمية المدفعية
تزداد ارباح الامريكان والغرب
يمر بمنعطف خطير. ليعلنها
الولايات المتحدة القوية طبقا
للصحيفة لديها مخزون محدود فقط
الاستراتيجي وذلك وفق سبوتنيك.
ومن التراشق بالتصريحات الى
في افغانستان. هناك خرجت
التصريحات الامريكية انهم
من الاسلحة التي يريدها
الاوكرانيون ويحتاجون اليها. الا
المزيد من الاسلحة. وذلك بحسب
صحيفة بوليتكو واوروبا تصرخ
ضربة من العرب والمكسيكيون
يتناولون كبسة السعودية قبل
المواجهة في المربع الاخضر. حرب
اوكرانيا تقسم الناتو. الحرب
ظل كل ذلك. قالت صحيفة نيويورك
تايمز ان الحرب الاوكرانية انهكت
الامريكي قد يوجه ضربة قاتلة
لصناعاتهم التي تعاني بالفعل في
الغرب والذخيرة قاربت على النفاذ
من مخازن الدول الغربية وحتى
وذلك وفق وكالة بلومبرج تبقى
كييب وحيدة في مواجهة موسكو في
ظل ارتفاع اسعار الطاقة الناجمة
عن الحرب الروسية في اوكرانيا
بين الاتحاد وواشنطن. حيث يرى
الاوروبيون ان قانون خفض التضخم
نوويين مرعبين. الصين تضم الدول
الاوروبية تحت بينما الولايات
قانون خفض التضخم الامريكي ادى
الى زيادة الانقسامات بين دول
يجب ان نعيد حساباتنا. الوضع لم
يعد في صالحنا. هنا منعطف
الحرب الاوكرانية?
المتحدة تصرخ وعدو جديد يظهر في
وجه التنين الصيني. تركيا تواصل
الاوروبيون. المستفيد الاكبر من
الحرب في اوكرانيا هي الولايات
تطول والخسائر تزداد والاحلاف
تتفسخ لكن روسيا لم تخسر بينما
المتحدة لانها تبيع المزيد من
الغاز وباسعار اعلى. ولانها تبيع
ضرباتها في العراق وسوريا وبغداد
تعلن التحدي. واردوغان يقولها
صراحة لا عداوة دائمة في
السياسة. الاسرائيليون يتلقون
تاريخي. الغرب يعيد حساباته في
الحرب الاوكرانية وامريكا هي
الضحية. اوكرانيا تلتهم الذخيرة
الغربية والغرب يشكو والكيان
الاسرائيلي يتخلى عن روسيا للضغط
على ايران وروسيا ترد بسلاحين
حرمتها. تسعطعش.